you can move you can move it you ever
why do you have your your bag that
because I just flew on a [ __ ]
airplane let me read to you guys what
will said to me and are you going now is
this the pause right now
hey everybody welcome to the ma'am
better not hear the keynote hey we've
got a great show for you we're gonna be
talking about some mixed martial arts
all right well lifestyle section yeah
excellent
all right lifestyle section and it's
sexual all right good job some knowledge
all right
well listen I get this some shop hey
we'll have fun
taking my spots today if Cal tried to
talk politics or something super boring
you have my permission to sock him in
his old fat dick now I go hey and then
sassa goes do you mean to say that when
people approach today's wide media
landscape seeking political coverage and
opinions that they shouldn't count t fat
K as a clear option I mean how are
people going to get their news if old
windbag McGrew Mick regurgitate Vaughn
something he heard doesn't play more on
Anderson Cooper with your listeners
whatever dude it's your show I'm like
will and then and then shot goes will
for president callum for sucking dick
really mature and then I go you got to
take this back guys and then I get this
from well in quotes hi my name is Jimmy
and I love the fighter and the kid when
I look for opinions I can trust today's
fast-paced news cycle I listen to Bryan
Callen or one of my dad's friends who
does whatever for a living and watches
Hannity sometimes then I get Bryan I'm
taking a [ __ ] and get an uber give you
an ETA soon yeah I was the air portal
you wanted to show up I showed up that's
my commitment to your listeners you want
to talk about what a die-hard guest host
/ sometimes guest I am of this podcast I
was just I've been I've been what are
the core of you been why you know don't
be so North York Virginia California
don't be so jealous I agree a ruler all
across he'll do so to turn to stuff work
off I love Pam the ham broke down lift
it's all fed in down to a me you know
just want a living as a singer I would
love nothing more than to set up shop in
Reno Nevada and sing the same songs over
and [ __ ] over again and just put up a
review you know and drive maybe a fancy
car like a sports car like a Miata well
canvass top because sometimes it rains
in Reno it's not quite Vegas go on I
think that being a rock star
I read this thing about like who
Radiohead was talking about what their
life was really like were you seeing the
same song over and over again and you
get on a plane or a bus with the same
band members and at one point they'd
been like on their 80th day or 200th day
touring and they just couldn't look at
each other anymore they just were like
I'm not gonna look at him I'm just gonna
sit here and get on a plane and go to
the next venue and sing the same song 80
or 90 days in a row yeah I think that's
something you know what I have to say
for them in their behalf yeah oh go
ahead Wayne working jobs for upwards of
5 years 10 years I know don't be
believing or get the same drop for 30
years I'm just saying balls are
Radiohead doesn't make music so it's
pretty easy watch for them to roll
around making whatever the [ __ ] it is
it's it's nothing since it's nothing bad
whatever they put on plastic Pete what
is that plastic fake plastic trees yeah
sorry for clearing my throat in your
listeners that song came out over 20
years ago Brian what I'm referring to is
the [ __ ] now I don't know yeah well
that's why you don't know from now ok ok
hey you know I was at the airport yeah
and I got you something you got me a
gift
yeah I got you a gift the airport all
right is that a snake yeah I'm a friend
for you cuz those it that was at the
airport and I thought you might enjoy
that and I come bearing gifts
Hollywood best woman yep so that was the
only one they had that's the only one
they happen you got me
what looks like an Oscar mm-hmm it looks
like an Oscar but it's not
it says Holly legal best woman it's his
best woman on it and that's for you why
would you do that because I wanted to
get you a nice gift from the airport as
your heaven - condescending gift oh yeah
and don't do that with your face as you
know what I'm saying and that's weird
don't that's weird on search hold on a
second hold on I don't know if my watch
is quite a checked it was 2018 yeah are
you saying that's insulting I'm just
saying that you gave me a well let me
ask you a question Brian in 2017 what
would you consider the year 2018 I I
don't know that would be the what what
would we call that - here are the woman
just one year it's the future Brian and
future's female and if you're gonna not
be a scumbag and you want to be equal
yeah - people like your wife yeah and
you know my girlfriend and your
girlfriends and Maya Angelou and my
Angela and you know I mean Julia Roberts
and people like that then you're gonna
have to embrace this so stop being a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I'm not a Jew end
of song
don't say I'm at best why are you not a
woman how do you think cause I'm a man
with a huge hold on big old honester
heavy balls that you have you that
create a lot of testosterone and semen
okay but that doesn't mean they're not
trying to be gross but they'll see it
but that doesn't my deal but that
doesn't mean that you can't be honored
and excited by me calling you a woman no
I can't say that you're that's my face
and I'm feet out like a [ __ ]
that may be how like a mother yeah that
may be but you're also all they had left
was woman and I mean I should be happy
I'm aggressive enough to fantasize about
punch you in the face until you die so
sort of so are some women that's true
well then what the [ __ ] but I don't
appreciate this you're being earned this
gift here give me and don't give that
back to me if I give you that back to
you Brian if you give that back
I will insert it into you now here's
that is that is how i'ma say I'm being
calm [ __ ] camera Brian I'm being calm
started in anywhere all I'm saying it
that's all I'm saying is I gave you a
gift if you decide to return that gift
to me that I thought you would enjoy
yeah careful now careful careful because
I'm gonna give you another chance
because what you just did is I will take
that gift yeah okay careful
insert it into yeah okay Brian
okay man's that would say that you know
I think you're being a [ __ ] thought
fascism yeah you are you just said you
were gonna you went with your finger you
did a loop and you push pointed you with
your finger went up in the air which
means that clearly isn't indication
you're gonna stick it right on myself
that's not what it means then what does
it mean I won't say you can drop from
this what you like well I got you a gift
it says that it's the best woman it's an
Oscar but not quite really yeah and you
should be honored to have that and it's
[ __ ] and the futures female yeah you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay you [ __ ] you just threatened and
if you don't threaten it if you don't
take this gift then you're not just a
piece of [ __ ] the [ __ ] thought
fascist you're a misogynist you spender
insert this e-mail and if you try to
give it back to me I'm being very calm
when I say the line i will inserted it
that's three times that you've
threatened okay to to essentially take
me serious thing
now let me keep it back mmm I want to
keep it over here and I'm gonna give it
back to you later
no I want you to I want you to feature
prominently here in your Studios I want
that's want you to build a little shelf
out of this now
the guy who makes this is a good guy it
took me a long time to etch that out if
you didn't know that some guy makes a
bunch of those in the California
countryside please ask him for a
similarly affected and diseased panel of
wood that you can screw into there as a
little shelf to put your best woman
award on your finger out of my face bro
I'll [ __ ] shove it up your whole list
I'll shove it right up your [ __ ] you
just said Oh blatantly where that Titans
got little creases on the side where it
was put together cuz it was made far
away by children with little hands huh
and that was a little edges cut now and
I'll [ __ ] Ram it up your balloon knot
and it'll hurt to [ __ ] for weeks if I do
that oh well you're so aggressively
[ __ ] little brown balloon nah don't
call it a brown thing like you know if
you took like bubblegum yeah like
chocolate do they make chocolate gum I
don't know dude and I'm sure down we're
and then just take your your nostril in
your ear hairs go bring and then just
twist it into the [ __ ] brown gum and
that's that's a replica of my that's
your [ __ ] and then take that [ __ ]
thing and try to put the gum on it like
a hat and you'll bleed okay how I'm
gonna ask you oh man do a reset yeah
well no I don't want to start over but I
do want to start metaphorically over
because you're obviously got some
problems that you're dealing with I
don't know what's in those drinks oh
[ __ ] I've been traveling what have you
been doing milk no we're going back to
shoot another season of Laudrup
Loudermilk lauric and you don't have as
well i'm having a stroke yeah Loudermilk
okay you can watch it on Amazon now much
louder get my special on Amazon Prime by
the way I just found out you can stream
it yeah you can also buy like you know
AC filters and you know do that dear
giant box of [ __ ] tooth or something
oh all right wait
whatever artist me with a box a
toothpick I'm trying to say I'm your
guest host I know well I'm saying that
watch Loudermilk on amazon and then you
said what about buy a humidifier on
amazon it's about people with substance
abuse problems ie Ron Livingston who is
a who you know sort of a group on that
sort of stuff tremendous actor plays
actor well he's tremendous is what he is
and I play his his roommate best friend
and sponsor I was going by the way I'm
drinking so it's a fun show and we're
going back to shoot another season it
was on the audience network you can get
it on the audience now or something an
app and the peter farrelly did it and
it's very
great guys and by Bobby Mort and we're
doing another season yeah all right but
I was in Atlanta shooting a different
show and then we're doing in Atlanta
Kevin probably saves the world it's an
ABC show you know Jason Ritter I know
all this pee I know everybody in
Hollywood but let me ask this he's a
sweetheart of a guy okay but what what
what are you first of all nice guy are
you a serious regular and the only would
ever threaten to push a cheap replica
how much you think that thing cost look
man that's your only solace when you're
facedown in the ER with a whom the
[ __ ] business end of an awards
madness really this would really hurt
yeah would especially if I got it down
to the root there no that's about as
thick as it gets down at the rear
I mean I really kind of think I know man
but this is you're threatening me with
with something pretty aggressive oh I'm
saying I would fight you off but here's
okay
if I come back here next time and it's
not prominently featured I'll get
another one can I be honest with you
what
I'm not kidding at 51 and I'm 51 yeah
that's right good round 50 I could
roundhouse you into the side of your
head and knock you the [ __ ] out you know
you would break your ankle no on my head
even if I was turning around like this
like boo and you hit me here would
change the way you walk for the rest of
time no my Ron else is stupid now yeah
yeah I get my shoulders into it a lot of
people think it's in the leg I bring my
shoulders around and then my hips and my
my foot is basically just there with the
legs of a rubber band with a with a
stone at the end of it yeah that's right
it's a rubber band
my legs are rubberband and I got a stone
for a foot and it's gonna go and it
doesn't climb off your head it goes
right through oh really you're like Mike
Tyson you you aim to the other side of
the eyes I finished I finished that cut
through yeah well you know you talk a
lot of [ __ ] and you talk a lot of game
when you come at me and I [ __ ] beg
yeah I beg you to try thank you
I want I want to be holding that I had a
bad award in the other in one hand and
I'll just be sizing you up with one hand
I got the award in the other hand and
you'll be you'll be pretty timid to go
swinging your legs this way and that
exposing that sweet sweet balloon not
Eeyore's cuz I'll get this right through
your [ __ ]
how much stitching you got in your jeans
no no just go read novel by the way
might might Taekwondo teacher who was a
Korean guy who who was boxed and did
judo black belt judo and a real fighter
and this bodybuilder came in to our
studio and he he looked at him and I
said how do you fight a guy like that
and he said I said good as a trampoline
very good trampoline and I said as I
made as the temple means a very nice
good muscles I'm jumping bong bong I'm
wrong and he said in other words I'll
knock him out and just jump on him like
a trampoline until he [ __ ] dies what
that was my career what martial arts
discipline is that well he was you know
technically Taekwondo but he knew
rattling dozer Locker never thought of
that
okay like wordplay I like to [ __ ] around
I want to ask you a question well I want
to get I want to get serious I heard a
there is this all this new report about
how you don't have to have a concussion
to have CTE that's so now this doctor
who did the main doctor of seizure and
concussion said I don't think any there
should be any contact sports for any
kids until they're 18 years old now
here's my question you played contact
sports you are and and I'm not saying
this to be a dick but you're a [ __ ]
idiot right no I'm not saying but if you
ask if you do a consensus he's a good
guy and he's good guy tell the guy but
he's a [ __ ] idiot right hold that
rage now who knows how much of that let
you finish your point who knows how much
you're like [ __ ] your daily [ __ ]
is is a result of head injury we don't
know we can't measure it right now the
daily [ __ ] a we're just you walk
around like no I'm gonna push that guy
and then I'm gonna go bad you know you
know what I mean and that's trying to
fall I'm trying to fall not trying to be
a dick but but no well you would admit
that you're a [ __ ] idiot but not I'm
a [ __ ] idiot
for the most part if you're like getting
me a little bit of milk on the audience
Network who [ __ ] cares that's what I
mean well that's that like I don't give
a sh that's an abrasive what you do
nobody cares right well you know right
I'll be the first to die
you could put your bag over there but
I'm gonna bring it really close to my
knee and crowd myself in and drink 17
[ __ ] gallons of all kinds of liquid I
wanted to give you your gift yeah but
you're a [ __ ] idiot no I'm not a
[ __ ] outdoor guy who played contact
sports do you think we should ban
contact sports uh first of all learn
about this stuff first of all I'd like
to take ownership some of the things
that you've said yeah and I know that
when it comes to my career and what I've
helped create and what I've been
fortunate enough to be a part on I take
it easy don't get emotional no I'd say
97 to 98% of that has been total [ __ ]
now okay all right so I understand when
you say like okay Loudermilk well well
look I just took I just don't be that
hard on yourself not 98 percent of it
you said they didn't work I flicked the
barbs off of your insult now I'd like to
continue Loudermilk is a quality [ __ ]
show okay okay and if you speak ill of
it one more time I'm gonna put that hot
day or don't say the award again with my
balloon not I don't it already hurts
just the thought and I don't and I
that's because it seems that's because
of the seams look how wide that
gentleman is you're gonna start a fight
as elbows at a physical fight on there
if you keep talking I think we could all
agree if I turn that upside down angry
if I turn that upside down yeah it would
hurt a whole lot more okay man when I
inserted John do I think that I went and
saw did you see concussion two three
years ago whenever we thought I lived it
I have a black belt in Taekwondo he's
gone and I wrestled anyway so yeah I got
played some contact sports I was you
know I was mostly addition it out rather
than receiving it you know an object in
motion tends to stay in motion and when
that object is a is a is a high school
phenom don't say phenom you were an
angry boy with a lot with a problem
three hundred and ten pounds of solid
brick it wasn't all brick well yeah it
was no blue no clue how to eat what's
protein what's a Republican no idea to
state at all I just did it all I got it
down there and I did some bench pressing
I did some deep
deep deep removing some weight without
high school yeah yeah yeah I did some
powerlifting and stuff why'd you bench
in high school oh you want to know what
my please be honest
max yeah Malcolm max are we talking like
cuz like I usually like to throw aid up
and I go like that's where I'm at you
throw what up 8 8 8 reps yeah alright
well that's fine I usually sometimes
we're like you know we're doing I mean
it's high school you know yeah but we
were all powerlifting and doing like
city competitions yeah city competition
some of my buddies yes sure yeah so you
know I some weight I wanted people to
come out of the room going you wouldn't
[ __ ] believe what's a so is pushing
up and then just like running through
the halls going bench
yeah backs max and don't be just now you
don't have to search for it cuz you know
and yeah I got a little tendinitis in my
right now so I'm not sure if I could do
this to this day well I'm asking what
you did in high school and you know the
number so and I don't appreciate the
pause because you're looking around six
hundred forty pounds that's not true
will no don't shrug your shoulders now
no you can't just go no hey that'd be a
rose for your listeners who can't see me
doing this right now the the you know
the audio equivalent is this well see
yeah I know yeah I know and and and
because you didn't tell me I didn't
bench press six hundred forty pounds
eight times eight hey will you 100
percent and definitely very obviously
without a question
didn't bench 640 pounds when you're in
high school or ever eight times mmm okay
see see see what I mean yeah so what did
you bench oh I know I didn't bench 640
pounds eight times
yeah or I'd rather that wasn't my max
cuz I benched at eight times my max max
was eight hundred eighty-five pounds I'd
say that would be a world record
basically and look up look it up in the
Canadian annex of sporting feats gonna
go to the Canadian ass please go to a
femaie TX of sporting feats dot CA got
dot see a guide Canadian annex of
forwarding feats feats yep well yeah if
you just put that yeah that's
let's see what it comes down to 15
biggest moments in Canadian sports are
you up in that I'm sure I'm number one
read off number one that's guy I've not
seen this article yet but number one yep
alright here we go ten biggest things
the urge to make less runs deep
alright come on this is gonna be a gene
to pal Vince cart always a slam-dunk
contest
Wow who gives all right that's a
sporting feet what happened on the
all-star week another curler captures
Olympic gold
look what hey I'm from Canada and this
is a piss-poor [ __ ] list all right
just get to number one all right well
swims Lake Ontario okay who cares
chaiwalla goes the distance with Ollie
you didn't win bro you went the distance
so Canadian to just to just survive take
second yeah second he [ __ ] he was in
there like a bag of meat Canadian woman
takes 1928 Olympics by storm that was
only a hundred and fifty five years ago
hey Gretzky - Lemieux yeah blah blah
everything Gretzky ever did yeah yeah
yeah all right Mike Weir wins the master
don't know what any of that means keep
going Barbara head scott takes stage is
gold that's a big who gives a [ __ ] Wayne
Gretzky again who's traded LA yeah
leaving Canada was a big moment in
Canadian sport area Fox versus across
Canada that's the only good one that one
should be number one if it's not me John
wins for a moment a hundred meter go a
guy with shoulders like like ripe
Halloween pumpkins yes
filled with gas yeah on roids yes one
something for a few minutes and that's
Sidney Crosby scores the golden goal
whatever lots of those have happened the
Blue Jays went back-to-back World Series
Wow all-america number two Donovan
Bailey Sprint's to build in Atlanta that
was pretty cool yeah that was pretty
good
later black oh that one poor Canada
great in 1993 Will Sasso I don't see
that 640 Penn I know where is that where
he reminds where are your friends I'm
looking at the website oh my god y'all
have a little sass was just a stage name
Paul Henderson was my I was my name in
high
I'm not Italian or any of that [ __ ] Will
Sasso Oh weightless I saw but I could
get to you know what I wanted to do when
I moved to Hollywood wife I want to get
this part you can't park here you know
like the guy in the movie you want to
take the hero comes yeah yeah pulls it
to the side and he's chasing the girl
and the guy comes out in like a like and
he's got dough on his hands he goes what
do you can't park here
I want to York I want to show you then
he goes peepee and he tosses me the keys
to a hot car like a Miata with the
answer because I want to show you
because here Chris decided to have an
act off with me and I'll just play it
for you he's in a towel in a towel and
he's doing it to me don't tell me this
is real acting and he said [ __ ] no it's
cool I think he gets into the camera
space just take for a sec what is this
from what do you found him don't we love
each other I love this sort of Jason
Statham unrequited Gale of things but he
want to show me I'm about his acting
that's really good acting though it's
good acting I feel like you if you were
to play a character
what would your character be would it be
English as well if I were if I were to
do an acting like how would you respond
to what he just said to you how did you
did you do an odd British name now I
didn't well you're doing I didn't I
would talk like this I'd be like you
know like a well odd night from like
Manchester all right
East London Lord this okay so so I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be an American
tourist okay
who's
has been picked up in a van and brought
to you yeah because I owe a debt okay
and I'm gonna try to get out of the debt
now I'm gonna just you probably it
because you want me to talk maybe you
have my feet in ice water look and they
keep applying ice to the water right and
you know you can't prove anything but
I'm just my feet are obviously in
tremendous pain
what's your character's name my
character's name is Connor Bailey Kona
Bailey yeah and I'm just here to enjoy
London with my family you should get
over to see Big Ben yeah I've not I
listen idea I don't know what this is
about I just got off a plane and I got
pushed into a van if there's something
I've done to it back in the Viking times
yeah they used to have a tradition yeah
with those who snitched I know they
didn't call it that
yeah I never snitched on anyone they
would take off his leggings his boots
made from the skull and head skin of
caribou yeah yeah what are you doing
excuse me
put him in ice Oh Oh what are you doing
no I can didn't talk why are you putting
my feet on ice yeah it seemed blah it's
a boring scene okay but it was pretty
good no wasn't really good because I
need a real acting partner like Ron
Livingston
could I check it out on Amazon and hey
while you're at Amazon think about bryan
callen special gets 16 boxes of Colgate
extra whitening dude baby that's not
especially
is it Audrey maybe it's streaming on
Amazon Prime
yeah oh that's right he's called never
grow up yeah that's good thanks buddy
what's the next frontier in comedy Bryan
Callen and he's gonna do a showcase what
do you want to do next income you're
doing a showcase well I got a showcase
for the powers that be at The Improv on
the 28th of February why you know you
got to show them what you're what you're
working with what you're capable of and
when I blow them away when I used to
love them away no I'm not familiar with
the world of yes I still have stand-up
yes
so wait you have to let go and do your
[ __ ]
just in a room but there's people there
right there's gonna be an audience there
right yeah well that's I mean the
problem isn't a lot of like they don't
know it's not just now in a room like hi
my name is Bryan Callen what do you mean
they don't know you as a cop I don't and
I'm no no no these Netflix's and things
like that
oh yeah well things that there's also a
DJ's you know there's also a there's a
there's a cool clique kids club there's
there's lots of stuff that you have to
get through there in case very few
people are making that decision
sometimes it's one person and they have
a very strong point of view on what they
like it's common that's right and
usually they're their significant other
and/or children at home are helping them
make those those that's very true and
none of them know who you are all right
well no no but it's true like you have
to know just think how I knew a really
successful and very famous director who
wrote a script and said to me I said
how's it going and she said to me I
don't know I can't get anybody to read
it and I went put your famous I mean
your well yeah and nobody reads it yeah
in fact what they do is they read they
skim it on a plane yeah and call you
with general notes and you're like what
you haven't read my script well you know
what I think I think that a lot of this
is sort of in a business that's
completely you know it's just completely
fabricated it's human made and human
designed and it's that you know the city
is not here based on any sort of natural
resource or a porch or anything like
that that's Charlie Chaplin showed up
and it's just this one interception it's
just pretty much totally perception it's
totally and also it's based on mood and
I kind of feel like sometimes I'll read
something you know as an actor you'll
read something and you'd be like whether
you're gonna go in an audition or it's
something they're interested in before
and you go like I don't know if I like
it that's just kind of sometimes can be
and I'm not saying you know it's
sometimes it's really to the mood you're
in
yeah you're kind of like I don't know
how what the [ __ ] because you're
questioning all the other whimsical I
retain your things that are spinning up
in the sky and but on the other side of
it let me [ __ ] finish it's really
you've got to learn to let people feel
sorry man don't be like
this story I didn't do it down someone's
in the middle we get back on what you
were saying anyway the other side of it
is you know sometimes people get really
excited about what they what they have
in front of them normally they don't oh
oh oh and by the way no one wants to
work and they just want to you know sort
of pay for their expensive cars and
their inflated mortgages and everyone
[ __ ] off a little bit before
Thanksgiving doesn't show up until about
now the middle of January and then
things start cooking again because
people do need to you know buy things
and take their families on vacation [ __ ]
so I said I guess what I'm trying to say
in a pragmatic way is find out what
someone's what someone's you know
spending is at what their what their
budget looks like and when people need
to sell [ __ ] and then get them on a
plane with a [ __ ] script otherwise
your friend has no [ __ ] shot and none
of us do and it's a miracle anything
gets made but but yeah unlike radio ad
we should all be grateful and thankful
to be in this bizarre bizarre erling
tempest nothingness did I ever tell you
because you yeah are a grown man yeah
lovely just a beautiful life really you
have a beautiful wife and family yeah a
beautiful home yeah wonderful
people who I want to enjoy what you do
like like here at the fighter and the
kid home and so many things that you're
doing like like not just the Goldbergs
but now school's out where they call
schools in the old rules of that schools
schools old don't it's no smoking in the
boys room what is it's called school
cool I just say right old school school
school school II schooled school days so
school time and you're do you be a day
anyway so and you got stuff like that
and you dropped out of high school and
never went to call I did not drop
graduated from college that's a vicious
rumor so what were you saying before
well one time speaking of things that
don't work right along we're about this
big scene Kevin Hart Laurence Fishburne
a bunch of other people huge movie and
it's a fight scene and it's a huge day
stunt people are over here the room is
it couldn't be more full of people and
you know it's one of those days I'm
like that's probably a million-dollar
day and we walk in and Laurence
Fishburne who's driving the whole scene
it's me John Leguizamo Kevin Hart
Fishburne director and Fishburne looks
at the script as we're reading it and by
me he looks up and he goes you know this
doesn't work right and and Tim stories
are great guy goes it doesn't work and
he goes and fish money goes yeah but
we're gonna fix it
just like that and fix it they did they
they did and everybody kind of went whoa
this is like everybody kind of froze
like wait a minute if he doesn't think
it's gonna work this is a million dollar
day what we're gonna fix it that's that
yeah that's but that's that is a real
act that's a real act and sometimes I
don't know about you but sometimes I
don't
hey everybody listening you can kind of
just [ __ ] off for 10 minutes because now
we're gonna talk like actors right yeah
and more kick and punch and show that
award up your take-up ooh yeah go make a
poopoo you guys got to take a poo break
that's gonna make but you know a lot of
a lot of actors just kind of hang in the
cut and kind of do whatever the [ __ ]
they're told which is fine you know when
you're doing the kind of [ __ ] you do but
sometimes actors like a guy who is
shouldering the project he literally has
to do that and you know you'll you see
these guys do [ __ ] like that and you're
kind of like whoa like for the first
half second is like is he being a dick
no he's a pro among pros who not only
knows that it doesn't work and knows
exactly why and it's done his homework
but also knows how to fix fix it poo
break over that's how it happens though
as you get older like what I'm noticing
at 51 is I'll read some things up here's
something that doesn't feel right and I
used to go well they're a journalists
are they're an academic and so they're
they're an expert on the field and they
have this thought and it's cool my to
disagree with it and now I go wait a
minute
first of all the person is younger
second of all just because you have a
degree or you're a quote-unquote
journalist doesn't mean a [ __ ] thing
no not a [ __ ] thing you know the
point of view based on a whole bunch of
opinions and attitudes yeah and
sometimes I feel it's my duty as I get
older even though I look 35 and we know
that and I look like all the time
yep you look 35 and you move like you're
30
five you look like you've liked it 35
that's important because because because
you don't know what that's about but I
my body does whatever I tell it to you
you look like a weathered 35 year old
would you put up the picture of the
singer of The Pogues Ian McKellen I know
you're lying miss Ellen yeah it is and I
and I'm a fan of Shane MacGowan whatever
sounded so these pictures are olive
these are all Pamela's a Shane MacGowan
yeah he's a heroin addict roughly 35
years ago he had some prawns oh you look
like yeah he's got a few there he is
so he you know he mixes him up he has a
Shandy with breakfast he's got some
issues with when it comes to he's had
some big well he's been drinking
yeah and heroin in McGowan he's a fan of
Harold he's a Scot again he's a Scot
he's got no [ __ ] teeth yeah but he's
13 he's probably 27 years old there so I
could see how you could I saw him do I
ever in a think it was CBGB's in New
York City and he came out so [ __ ] up
but goddamn I love his music yeah he's a
real [ __ ] poet yeah look at those
teeth Shane Shane was a bad teeth
there's a real bad tooth so anyway
you're 35 looking he and you know why
Steve kept falling he was just fall flat
on his face after talking about his
teeth the rotten because he's drinking
all right man all he's doing is drinking
he needs he would fall flat on his face
he had these perfect pearly whites and
then he fell on the cobblestone street
Meyer and he's not it doesn't it doesn't
tell nice there's some beautiful songs
put on um put on rainy night in Soho
that's a great song but there's another
song but I just put up bring up the
Pogues let me see something
the Pogues a fairytale in New York oh
it's a good great Christmas great so
very till very till in New York
everybody if I should fall from the
grace of God another pool break that's a
great song
this is one of the great songs ever
13 minutes long it was crazy
[Music]
[Music]
face away look at him he's so great
though
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think of that music it's
about to get Christmas here that's a
word
hey anyway listen of the pose cuz
they're asking punk rockers - oh yeah
dude The Pogues are there [ __ ] the Pope
the Pogues are they've also got songs
like about foot just opposing the grace
of God what no angel' gonna receive me
he goes through this hole there there
punk they're also really did I see Ian
McKellen yeah you did and I was like
[ __ ] actor che Maga yeah you did and
I'll Shane McAlary smile because it
doesn't matter I don't really know what
yeah 47 million views by the way how
about that that's how big the Pokes used
to be yep yeah and he had some problems
he died of alcohol related issues did he
die at the age of 36 I didn't know that
no I don't know he's still life I think
he's still alive
yeah ya know you got new teeth actually
yeah it looks alright
he might be you might be clean what else
is going on with you nothing you gonna
go do stand-up no but I mean it what's
the next what's the next what's the next
frontier in in live continously for me
just I just want to keep
actually selling their oh that doesn't I
want to and I want to actually just keep
writing I want to get closer to writing
exactly how I feel about the world
instead of just trying to be funny
that's good yeah that'd be good like
trying to say something without being a
dick about it
you know cuz you get to a point where
being silly becomes kind of easy right
or just not even making people laugh is
one thing that's that's a bag of tricks
but then like kind of marrying that to
stuff that you actually really give a
[ __ ] about one of things about having
kids is that you can't avoid being
philosophically and politically
committed because the world's a [ __ ]
or sometimes you start watching the
wrong ideas take hold and you get very
worried I worry about that [ __ ] I worry
a lot about where we're getting our news
and how people can make their living off
of whatever it might be with you know
everybody now is a journalist if you
have a blog if you've got an online
publication yeah you can say [ __ ] and
you know and now with algorithms you
know Facebook and Google we talked about
this last night Facebook Google Apple
and and who is the other company and
Amazon are the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse they basically are we're
controlling all of your news and they
have algorithms that can push the news
you think they think you want to hear
and that stagers your goddamn points of
view and your opinion you're living your
own echo-chamber kit and i now go and
create your own [ __ ] yeah it'll
create your own algorithm that's very
dangerous no that is very dangerous but
also the the other side of it is nobody
knows I mean you know traditional media
sources are just getting picked off left
and right yeah by people on both sides
of the aisle saying well that's kind of
[ __ ] and this is kind of [ __ ]
right because the culture has been you
know well you know I mean
what's-his-face said fake news right
yeah and then but then you sort of I
have a hard time watching some like yeah
I don't know I'm you watch like I mean I
don't want to [ __ ] on like one versus
another or whatever but you know you'll
watch like CNN you just like what CNN is
petty I'm sorry I'm CNN I like it's I
can't take it
CNN actually gets in tit-for-tat fights
with the president yeah you've got
you've got journalists that aren't even
journalists there they're more
interested in being celebrities and
getting their point of view out but I
also checked it but also you have to
remember it's like it's such a TV show
it is a TV show ratings are more
important than on Monday I thought that
the presidential address was on Monday
and said Tuesday or something I saw it
online so I turned on YouTube and there
was this and the first the only thing
that had it like running streaming was
was they just there was a stream from
Fox News and I was like okay the address
will be on here and then you're watching
Fox News and and it's like hey we've got
our coverage the day before the address
coverage of the address yeah you know I
mean I don't want to I'm not cool and
that's not exactly what they called it
but they were talking they need to fill
the right footing all the stuff said all
the banners were like presidential
address blah blah blah and I had a hard
time going it was like walking into a
casino and trying to figure out what the
time is there's no clocks right right so
you're kind of going like what the [ __ ]
am I even listening to hear what the guy
they what the [ __ ] of these guys
yammering on or on about and this is an
eight-hour block because they have to
fill TV time that's right and we forget
I mean we you know people in the
business of television can tell you oh
well you know whatever the [ __ ] the
ratings are cells
I was watching I was watching I was in
Canada yesterday I flew flew here you
know just now so I was watching the
address last night with my parents at my
parents house and then afterwards on CTV
News you know they talked about it for a
little while and then they went on to
other [ __ ] you know what I mean which in
Canada is a lot about like there's like
a couple murders and stuff like that
that's all the you know because like I
think in Canada probably one or two
maybe two people die and every six
months period and that includes natural
death no one's dying no and I don't
really think about it before they you
know pair up and have a kid that's sort
of so it's really that's why there's
only you know 18 people yeah there's
something like Ontario 18 people yeah so
but you're watching the news in Canada
and it's like
oh they sure are moving on to something
different well because they're just
almost about at a time and they're gonna
run a little you know a rerun a littlest
hobo that's a little inside humor for
Canadians everybody hey okay so show
about a dog so anyway um you know they
move on another [ __ ] now you contrast
that to the American news channel
whether it's Fox News or CNN or MSNBC or
whatever and it's like you have to
remind yourself these are TV shows also
we have forgotten sort of what you know
there's no Walter Cronkite anymore who's
just a newsman right nobody wants our
ground what what you're so if you have a
point of view they go what are your
sources and nobody even agrees that your
sources who usually we're at a source
and we all trusted in that source now
it's like yeah but you're getting your
news from and so there's no there's no
tax on that no one's safe from it
they're saying like oh now like the
Washington Post they'll chop the legs up
for money if you say well I got this
from the Walker who the [ __ ] are they
here's the other word is that Bessel's
yes you can create a news
you can create a news feed right so you
can say anything you want Donald Trump
has affair with this porn actress okay
and okay so that's news what people all
realize is that the journalist that
comes up with that story
that's clickbait and you can sell that
to a hundred and fifty other news places
so it becomes where news and even gossip
or whatever it might be that people
actually you know that I can do people
like to see people fall sure that is
valuable that makes money for the news
organization because you can sell it 15
times over a hundred times over yeah and
that's what I worry about where there's
real profit in and if somebody if any of
you guys are listening and know stuff
about that semi stuff on that I want to
read about it occasionally you sounded
you know I'm not gonna say you're not an
intelligent guy I know you're very
well-read but you sounded like a stupid
idiot just then wow just finished this
whole thing with your opinion you worded
it perfectly adding was fine and I was
like you know what Brian then you go and
by the way anyone
- hazard stuff send it that's not what I
meant
I just meant there it would mean pills
and I like to ER a and ro some listeners
who hate you for the most part but you
were filler right now that's not that
send me some good stuff to read and it
opens my eyes to it I want to say two
things number one we're doing exactly
what Brendan asked me to make sure that
you do not do what's happing about
politics all right man
number two I want to say that 10-minute
podcast is still going strong all right
not really no why not we're giving it
away are you when you're gonna weigh
myself Chad Kultgen and Tommy blocka are
giving away the podcasts coming up on
six years of the podcasts been around
you just course you and Chris D'Elia
were pioneers of the place in
trailblazers dudes with a podcast and
and and that can't build can't build a
bunch of sound we thought that shed
about that yurt yeah that yeah we did
build that year totally your anyway you
know I was gonna say you know something
usually when I come on here I say hey
come on over 10 min upon cast check it
out get on iTunes and stuff I'm gonna
say to your listening audience now only
go over to ten minute podcast if you're
curious what happens after 10 min upon
cast yeah yeah well I think I've
mentioned here what we call the diamond
ding which is we're just pouring down
the audience just crushing it like a
piece of coal you haven't down to one
listener well the the intention honestly
was to get the thing so inside this is
Tommy blotches idea and then Chad coined
at the diamond name to pair the audience
down to one listener who gets every
reference because it's just completely
cross-referenced not only with like
stuff you know perhaps from the past
from my point of view but then like
arcane wrestling references and weird
[ __ ] the Chad says and then ways that we
sort of play on that and just it makes
no sense anymore it makes no sense
anymore
we're losing thousands of listeners
we're keeping we've lost all of our
sponsors
all of them were gone and we've done
this on purpose and we've now turned the
diamond into
on the ground till you disappear and
we're giving it left put some dust and
flies and then we're giving it to some
dude named Mark to build it back up so
you're knocking ash and saying build
this Phoenix back up no we're giving him
a hard [ __ ] diamond and we're saying
upon this diamond build ye a house huh
and and that's what Mark's very strange
though it seems like it's funny and
weird well but also it's like who gives
a [ __ ] it's a podcast it's not like you
don't mean you guys have turned this
podcast into an industry yeah that's one
thing most podcasts or podcasts yeah
yeah so who gives a [ __ ] yeah so and
we're like well we have any plans and
starting we're doing another thing yeah
we're doing a new thing what would that
be well we don't well we're just about I
got no rest no no no we want it to not
be about that okay I'll tell you what
don't call it professional wrestling
[ __ ] Wow it's a highest art form and
that's very that's a very controversial
thing to say I'll do all due respect I
don't I don't know if I think that well
I think it's a word season right now and
instead of you know all this you know
all the show business yeah patting
themselves on the back and all that
stuff during award season
I think the WWE Slammy Awards should air
you know Slammy Award yeah she they
hosted by word by James Corden you know
what I mean yeah and maybe have you know
Bruno Mars come on those guys were you a
thing and then would Jessica Chastain
and Matt Damon couldn't have a speech
about some [ __ ] I think they'd watch
that well I think that they should host
the Slammy Award you know that I work
with Goldberg yes my brothers yeah you
know do you know him have you worked
with him I know I have I mean I've met
him metal but I said who's very nice
because I got no okay well you know what
what a weird thing to say out of nowhere
it kind of tells me who cares yeah oh
that's a good goal
don't ask me question though I don't
really give a [ __ ] you know cool bird
come here so big and muscular now that's
a dumb question no wrestling family to
lift he's got a he was your favorite
restaurant overall gives a [ __ ] you told
me that you bit somebody's chin off once
yeah I did
all right well in a street fight I was
growing up in Scotland I don't see I
don't believe that unites the island in
the 1960 you have no accent when I was
20 well I got rid of 20 how old would
that make you dude right now you'd be 65
now I'm 35 years old so 30 yeah 36 what
were we talking about oh yeah a
10-minute podcast we're giving it away
so listen to it to see what's going on
next but it doesn't [ __ ] matter don't
bother it's [ __ ] weird oh it's super
weird now yeah man it makes no [ __ ]
sense
great I just turn on the require start
recording they don't know that I'm
recording yeah I got these two idiots
talking about [ __ ] toys the other day
like gi old-school GI Joes do have any
clips of it boring as [ __ ] no I don't
want to talk about all right all you
want to doing those clip bits no you
watched any are you watching yeah
football you got you got it you got a
pic in this this year's I'm going to the
game you are me and Marshall bit killer
Jones junior cook really yeah how did
you guys get this I got tickets through
the audience Network yep through the
audience network proudly airing a louder
note I don't hey come on by it's on
Amazon Helen you think of Bryan Callen
now you get yourself some filters for
your air conditioning no noted and fine
ever grow up never grow up on DVD and
VHS no you can watch Rhema and stream
now it just doesn't come out on VHS
[ __ ] you're a thing comes out on
Betamax nope you know I bought a video
on VHS not too long ago because I
couldn't find it on really what Coupe
DeVille starring Daniel Stern who else
is in it alan arkin I'll do that
somebody backed and watch movies like
chariots of fire or Young Frankenstein
if you have brothers yeah watch Coupe
DeVille you don't have any brothers
you're just qualified I have an older
brother I can watch Coupe de Ville yeah
yeah so what I was gonna say is yeah
we're going through we're going with
audience Network they got a bunch of
budget it's okay besides it gives a
[ __ ] besides Loudermilk yeah I'd love
to tell you what you want to hear about
the lineup yeah they've got it doesn't
matter they've got BMX showdown
ah it's a show with bikes when they show
down yeah it's like it's like it's off
with bikes and rev their engines engines
the yeah and then there's ooh with their
mouths one mum mum yeah and then there's
a Ashoka uncles and aunts that's good
job who have sex and they and they give
birth to unfortunately children that yep
yeah that's that show okay and then they
have a show called career lady gets
married career lady gets married and
then her career gets ruined and she gets
on hooked on valium well that's my -
okay well that's kind of a that's kind
of a leap and then they got oh I got all
sorts of shows quest for breathe Oh
Islands for fire quest for burrito I
know for burrito Island yeah it's a
reality show guys go people go out there
try to eat it load of burritos and then
somebody gets in the tube they attach a
sort of it's a it's a fart chamber still
then they everybody's eating that
burrito somebody's gonna tell you seeing
the whole group has a tube attached
their ass and they fart into the the
unto the cylinder and you have to
breathe farts yep that's a rich Astorga
live richest dog alive that's a good
show that's a fun show where they were
they where the dog is rich but for the
first time they starve it and they put
convicts in a cage with it and the dog
killed how about a rich this is just
better rich dog and now those are all
fake shows good don't swerve like that
and you're stupid Teavana
hate Starbucks are you at ivana or are
you Teavana
or are you [ __ ] Starbucks I think
they're trying to show that they've got
this cup company maybe that blonde
espresso roast is damn good I'm happy
with it
I haven't tried it it's good it's real
espresso I'm happy with it let's do some
current events
I'm sorry if I'm a little bit low energy
you know oh no you just got a little
energy what happened no I had three
hours of sleep two and a half hours
where'd you come from
yeah Lane well just from Vancouver but I
was up last night working on a [ __ ] I
think
well since was a big wrestling fan what
did you think of Ronda Rousey and the
rumble shown up and yeah showing up and
just being in well you know it's
probably gonna have program with Oscar
cuz Oscar is undefeated alright okay I
guess someone comes in watch rest I have
to like I sort of have to like no I
don't have well I don't have cable
anymore yeah so I watch it on Hulu they
have the WWE you know you can watch
their shows on Hulu and you can get
through them kind of quick I kind of
just want to know what they're doing you
know there are some things in wrestling
where I kind of like well I can tell you
what they're they're fake wrestling
always okay I mean that's not I mean no
I know when they're yelling at each
other so that's what they're doing no it
is no word for that is nothing
well Brian would someone call the great
works of Shakespeare nothing
well now see would someone call those
and she looks forward to winning at all
and my friend said but it's a place
that's a play and athletic play so how
do you win at all yeah although she
looks adorable there I think she's just
looking really really cute um I'll tell
you this right now
you know she'll probably win whatever
the heck her first match is but then
what they do she got to give it back you
know what I mean really she well she's
got a she's got a give back they Kate
the throng no I'm saying she's got to
like give back the the victory now you
know that's and that's how people you
stay interested they go who you know
about money her even though you asked me
for money sometimes I've never asked you
for money sir please no money please if
you take that back because well you have
them you ever you have not to spread
rumors but no I have a different you
have a drug problem I do have a [ __ ]
heavy drug yeah so let me ask you this
that's why you're wearing dentures right
now but let me ask you this check this
up Oh God my gir here's my Shane
McKellen ah in the gallon shame on the
gown Shane MacGowan
load him again
what kind of money you think she's
making for this [ __ ] do I know what the
[ __ ] what I know how much they make I
don't know a few hundred K or a million
bucks I don't [ __ ] know a lot of
money look at how many people who
slaughters the way she's Ronda Rousey
alright she's got a t-shirt on like a
hot rod rowdy rowdy places she looks at
this is hot Ronda she's a cutie pie I
love her she is a cutie pie they're all
cutie pies and now you've never been to
a wrestling event no I read and also I
when you go when you go and you sit up
close it's so you see how the how they
could so easily get hurt which I would
follow up with if I were Bryan Callen
for nothing and it's so easy for them to
get hurt and like the the gal on the
right in the last picture there mmm this
that's a little girl it's a little girls
little yeah tiny thing just I remember
going like a thing and you see these
these you know women going all out
because it's it's a big event and you're
just like you're doing a lot of yeah and
I did the same thing I remember when we
went and when we watched Brendan fight
in Vancouver rap and i sat there at cage
side going yeah you know what oh well
I'm trying to say I said and they all
say that the injury rate is crazy like
it's it is not easy you got to be an
athlete to be in you also have to know
you also have to have a dance partner
who knows what they're doing or else
someone's gonna get hurt
people get hurt bottom line is Bryan
yeah I want to speak to this as far as
wrestling fans yes talk to me and mixed
martial arts all right you know our dear
pal Brendan in the middle of a I train
is about literally needn't life and life
life and death so condescending okay I
said I trained you can't let me finish
what I'm saying don't shush me it's so
obnoxious I man if you say anything else
I'm not saying all I said was in passing
I train as well don't hold on let me
finish okay let me feel this you know
cuz I can hear it even though they don't
talk if you tie I can talk in my podcast
okay I said you're gonna hear all I said
was I trained and
you see let me finish what I'm saying
all right but don't coach okay don't
talk fine that's right quiet
right now all right let me finish okay
here's something you're talking I'm
trying to finish all right okay now I I
have the same you talking still you are
not a lot don't ya listen I have the
same reaction whether it's Ronda Rousey
in a you know in a leather coat yeah and
a little Alexa bliss over there slamming
each other around and doing their dance
right sure
as I do too Brendon in a life-and-death
battle you know in a real fight right
real fight in the cage UFC I mean and to
even to be that close to it man oh man
it's that's a different puts a different
paint job on things let me tell you and
it's the exact same reaction for me why
is that
why cuz I Shh I told you to shut the
[ __ ] up because I have I have what's
called an imagination okay now when you
have an imagination yeah I have an
imagination too
you know a lot of people watch mixed
martial arts or combat sports like this
you know whether it's boxing kickboxing
karate calendar you know I'm Alan doe is
right
nope just wits when a guy's one of 51
year old guy sits in the middle of a mat
tries to get hard not just I've never
done that dude really I've never sat in
the middle of a mat and tug my putt
especially a challenge oh you know what
I would love to see you do what I would
love to tell you I would love to see you
walk out in front of a small group of
pay a small paying audience yeah you
know in Cambodia or something why in a
ring when they're making you know they
got food running around they got people
serving food and they're fat and you
know how they have like yeah I got bets
going and there's just like you know
music fight before that
I remain two animals two different
animals who roosters yeah every now
maybe I inna maybe three roosters
there's one dog and two wild dogs yeah
that would be good yeah anything really
a ferret versus a jellyfish some weird
[ __ ] sure that stuff yeah and then the
main event Brian you come out in really
short Muay Thai shorts yeah right
and then you whip them off put that
award down sit on it get it up your ass
try to get hard in the middle of the
[ __ ] room this is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
think I have the [ __ ] you think you are
never do that I'm not that guy I'd pay
pay-per-view money for that give a [ __ ]
what you'd pay I would never do that I
would love to see walking out in
Cambodia after all these animals have
been fighting yeah and I'm not walking
out there 51 yeah
pulling down my super really short
shorts my time and then sitting on that
this thing's just a war that says best
woman I'm not sitting on that [ __ ]
yeah and getting your brown balloon not
all around that and sitting on it you
really brought this podcast down until I
was up into your large intestine I'm not
doing that [ __ ] you a bigger award I'll
get you I'll tell you what well I'll get
you a full Tower now you know from now
I'm gonna get you a bunch of every time
I'm in an airport I'm gonna get you
something that we can put up your ass
well you try to get your flaccid fish
dick hard in front of people eating you
know don't call it flashing and what's
the other thing larb
that's it Laura that's all ty you're
being you're assuming that I find it
more offensive that you're assuming that
Cambodian cuisine is the same as Thai
cuisine never say more offensive okay so
name one Cambodia jet car what's your
favorite what's your favorite Cambodian
dish you're too ignorant to even know
what it is I could tell you what it is
because I've spent time in that part of
the world and I have great deal respect
for for all different kinds of
essentially cuisine you know what mine
is what mung bean black bean and who can
stop right there because mung bean
belongs to to Vietnam okay of the to the
monkey
Oh No okay I don't know about that that
was so easy and you don't Anthony can
[ __ ] no black beans cuz that belongs
to Mako so at the end of the day you're
gonna waiting to and I felt very
offensive uh one of my favorite
Cambodian dishes yeah go ahead the
Cambodian BLT that what is that though
what's in it it's got you're making it
up see it alright you're already pausing
it's got goat bacon no goat there and
there's no coke bacon you can't make
bacon out of go uh god damn it River
lettuce there's zero ok wait a minute
River lettuce river leaves
you mean the lily they kind of like the
vegetation sort of floats on the top of
the rail Rio
spoken like a man who's been to Cambodia
finally yeah but they don't think you
can eat those that's that's giant lily
pads yeah and then and then you know
just your basic hothouse tomato on toast
well there's no toys in that's in the
new world so that doesn't belong to
Cambodia so what what do you mean
tomatoes forest tomatoes like tomatoes
the little ones that grow on the ground
some nice vine tomatoes same as you get
at Ralph's or Cambodia not in Cambodia I
don't think so oh I guess I guess the
last time I was in Cambodia in a
restaurant eating a Cambodian BLT
watching you get your puckered [ __ ]
my life your dick hard
nope I must have just been hallucinating
yeah yeah sure brings me back to my
point well I can watch you know some
mixed martial arts HAP and I can watch
some wrestling or you never you want to
call it happen and it's just it's all an
enchantment of the mind for me because I
have what's called an imagination serves
me well so I am fan of wrestling still I
like their colorful outfits and
personalities I like it when they say
I'm gonna win no I'm gonna win and then
you watch it and then Vince McMahon has
decided who's gonna win and then yeah ok
then you see that so it's fixed
the old times basically good the way God
it kind of has already decided your
destiny and you can do everything you
want you know at the end of the day
you're still gonna burn the lake of fire
if your will sasso right well you're off
you're even more on this go to the next
believers go to the next cuz I didn't
get out of here so I can get out of here
I gotta get the fungus right back to the
airport and fly you know you've made me
so sick I'm gonna fly back to Canada Wow
watch Canadians leopard you because
you're Canadian
I'm also America not really don't take
out I don't care about your passport I
don't I don't want to see it that's a
forgery not gonna look at it what's the
next current event a woman tried to
bring an emotional support peacock I
thought solid joke and Airlines a joke
so this is the actual peacock that she
brought into the airport that's [ __ ]
hilarious amazing and she got denied
obviously that's hilarious and here's
actually a footage of it some videos see
this this is great
emotional support peak luck only in
America
it just lands right on her shoulder or
her head - oh God but you have to you
have to register I don't know what the
what the process is but emotional some
an emotional support animal first of all
that thing's not wearing like the Yellow
Jacket she's and that woman's a cuckoo
bird you think I got a 40 pound bird on
my shoulder what what's the problem
yeah I saw a couple people walking
through the airport today with a couple
of really big dogs like beautiful dogs
clearly very well behaved ah but they
had that yellow little jacket on yes it
says there now there are now cracking
down line because you can get for $5.00
this is the woman transport woman look
at her [ __ ] socks she's an [ __ ]
figured out this news story now she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] well that's all it is
don't be that look at me and my
expensive bird all right check out these
socks what do you know what else you got
Vance recive about some casual and an
[ __ ] it's you know difficult but
don't call it an [ __ ] for that [ __ ]
that peacocks have not what the [ __ ]
were you thinking you're gonna go
through the things go crashing it's my
emotional support support peacock yeah
I guess that peacocks her friend uh-huh
yeah she's a chaser she's a stupid-ass
for that person I think she's an [ __ ]
she's got her phone and look at all that
[ __ ] she hasn't hit another phone her
hands he's barely he's got problems
yeah she's got [ __ ] problems but
she's got bubblegum in any [ __ ] bags
will sasso the female will sasso it was
16 things in his hand
yep she looks like compete 35 year old
toothless bryan callen shot just
speaking of peacock and turn it around
pulling his muay thai shorts down to
expose the butt end of an airport bot
award and it from an just some blood
trickling down onto his balls okay
because he [ __ ] slit his [ __ ]
[ __ ] seams of a cheap plastic award
that thing cost me 16 dollars by the way
get it up your ass get that put it in
your ass man I'm not doing whatever if I
come back here next time and that thing
doesn't smell like [ __ ] I will slap you
raw on your [ __ ] podcast man that
thing better smell like the inside of
your [ __ ] food hole all right sweet I
don't give a [ __ ] your hand get that
[ __ ] ward up your ass bryan callen
here encapsulate give a [ __ ] what your
opinion is your fake news your fake news
here's your [ __ ] award
you wanna [ __ ] up your [ __ ] two in
one fell swoop as a matter of fact you
know what just put the head of it in
your tight little balloon and then just
jump up and sit on it okay I mean okay
I'm MJ I'm sorry I want to apologize to
MJ I'm sorry who's a young intern with
her life ahead of her and she's being
exposed to this [ __ ] heathen ogre
yeah and I'm sorry
look you got candles around here you got
five candles my friend Johnny my Jenna
friend Johnny was a really special guy
and he said seven don't give anybody too
much power of you and I said why they
said because when people have all the
power of you they'll do terrible things
to her I said that's probably true and
he said they'll reach in your ass and
polish it up Oh what yeah a friend who
says bizarre [ __ ] I go he's
some amazing things I go what he goes
they'll just reach in your ass and pull
his [ __ ] out of it I go things that
somebody that's power we would do I
don't think they'd reason he hasn't
polish [ __ ] I don't think that's
possible doesn't make sense come over
the bed then that we were driving then
why doesn't well you know Charlie Johnny
oh yeah Johnny from the neighborhood
about five days he come Johnny fabulous
and he goes he guys were driving and I
was like forty and he was you know forty
eight and he goes all seriousness he
looks at me he goes we should start a
band who know and I go that's a really
good idea and he goes yep and I go what
would I play goes I would imagine
whatever you know I go what would you do
and he goes I would sing I go alright we
just kept driving and then I was lying
in the bed and he goes what's going on
but my legs are so sore I worked out and
he reached down and began to rub my
ankles and I go Jesus that feels good
and he goes I know cuz I'm rubbing the
connective tissue in your legs and I go
god damn it and he goes I always wanted
to write a novel about that and that
went all right so those are the things
and the fourth thing he said was he said
I gotta get out of LA and I said why and
he said because I get really tired of
fixing things with my eyes nobody knows
how to make anything beautiful around
here and he was a painter and he was he
was he's on the spectrum but one of the
most beautiful people I ever met and he
sounds like he's on the special I loved
it and I [ __ ] loved it I wait please
say that again my eyes what I have to
fix things with I hurt I usually I got
to get out of LA I said why goes because
my eyes are hurt because I'm fixing
things all the day all day cuz knows how
to make anything beautiful yeah he's on
the spectrum right now but he was right
yeah there's no flow here now there's no
flow from one thing to another yeah just
a bunch of little islands ya know yeah
that's true little islands little little
but a price I'm making beautiful
beautiful things right you can't put a
price on creating beauty all [ __ ]
aside I think we take it for granted but
like architecture like [ __ ] like that
that took forever like you know you see
like a building that's beautiful versus
a building that's built just for
efficiency you know it's like you know
my [ __ ]
or building that's built real cheap yeah
hey how about that target on East Sunset
Boulevard out and more stuff you don't
need well no no I'm talking about the
one that was not built to code I'm kind
of a nerd for this stuff did you hear
about this now over by the Home Depot
way on East you know in East Hollywood
there well excuse me everybody I just
drank three different Oh drinks coming
back to haunt me now yeah coffee water
and a green tree no it's going inside of
me going horrible girl we know hey Brian
and trying out for the Milwaukee Brewers
you see what I mean Bruin the [ __ ]
yeah no they built a thing not to code
and it's literally like two or three
feet high higher than it should be and
they're like stop oh boy and you dumb
shits you [ __ ] now have stopped a
multi-million dollar project here sad
the sad half built shell of a target
sticking out of the ground at Sunset
Boulevard and Western and he was lost
yet another legal manager need a target
there I guess maybe people need this
shot sure they need a bunch of targets
but they just built it you know whatever
it is google it if you feel the muse but
it's just a you know a couple a couple
inches too high because yeah it was
built for four reasons that are adverse
to art Brian the artistic eye and
understand or appreciate right that's it
would it's a deeper than that function
for West when a city is built around one
function it'll tend to be very uniform
and soul-killing yeah you can't have
that you gotta have some artistic
inspiration yep in the building like a
statue of a man on one foot arms
outstretched yeah in a lean forward to
sort of a yearning to move forward yeah
and and it is a man yeah let me ask
white and his name is Brian Kelly were
sneaking out of his ass no maybe a good
step that you pay people to throw you in
a diaper and spank the [ __ ] out of your
really discipline you powder your
[ __ ] and then throw a diaper on you
stick a bottle in your mouth yeah and
then beat you close this Bell
closed fist brews you up no wedding Oh
banana no weapons
yeah I like a woman with a with a with a
petite and delicate hand yeah
balled up with a roll of quarters in it
uh-huh hit me in the [ __ ] nose as
hard as you can break my [ __ ] nose
sweetie pie yeah see you say I like to
get a woman around make my [ __ ] nose
out one bill maybe you know 110 pounds
yeah like a little like a very a petite
woman yeah petite woman like Jim I've
won yeah yeah yeah athletic but you know
put very very feminine and you almost
lot of cash in her hand to do what no
I'll just ask her oh yeah that's kind of
my opener you know a lot of people say
that now it's really hard to meet
significant other in public yeah right
everyone's on all the apps right call
them apps yeah fumble tatters you
Harmony's the apps yeah there are apps
sure they're apps I say no go the other
way cut against the grain that's what I
do and I go up and I just talk to women
you know my opening opening line is
usually hello and then from there I say
what do you say we blow this joint go
back to my place I'll get into an adult
sized diaper
yeah with velcro extensions on the I'm a
little little bit heavy right now yeah
and I just want you to ball up your
beautiful little fist okay
don't worry you're not gonna break your
nails because in your hand we're gonna
put a roll of quarters okay
smash my [ __ ] nose off of my face and
right why what else where else tell you
nine times out of ten they they they
stick around for another door where else
should we hit which just my nose
repeatedly okay and when I'm unconscious
stuff stomp on my balls and if you can
flip me over onto my stomach out now
putting the ward man no all right all
right let's move on let's move on this
has been a very very difficult podcast
to listen to let's go to the next one
Joe candidate explains drool during
speech the Assizes mouth yeah it was so
like very wet normally oh yeah yep yeah
there's a little bit light on the
chapstick so yeah you'll see right here
placed together as our nation reflects
on the state of our union this is a
difficult task look at the corners of
his mouth many have spent the last year
anxious angry afraid to wipe their
mouths feel the fractured fault lines
across our country we hear the voices
those Americans who are for guy who pees
him out of jobs and feel forsaken what's
going on well what was his explanation
people thought he was drooling he had
too much chapstick on he had too much
chapstick he thought the house is
responsive make a person will give you
will all it was offer chapstick and
you're not that experienced you'll say
sure and then you don't put it on the
sides of your mouth though yeah that's
that'll happen yeah that's where you
might as well you might as well rub it
on your eyebrows but like you were
alluding to earlier with regard to with
it noise with regard to the the news
cycle Brian perception is everything
yeah and now he's you know Trump's gonna
come up with some juice I really truly
nickname for him and that'll be the end
of that little Marco lying Ted yeah
stupid Jeb really Joe really Jeff really
Joe yep - hey Joe
shiny Joe - Joe Kennedy negotiate with
China
he can't agree with China because of
Israel this is true he's a drooly boy is
it Julia boy all right let's see the
next [ __ ] I want to ask you about
this Brian so there's a big-game hunter
who was legally shooting Lions he killed
one lion he tried to shoot another one
as soon as he was about to pull the
trigger
he got shot someone killed him they
don't know who it is yet either oh my
goodness so he was off in Africa South
Africa shooting what is in something
called something called canned hunting
have you ever hunted rip no they they
have us so they have an error
where they release the line that's been
bred in captivity yeah exactly hey money
to kill it so they breathe these lions
doing they're trying to do send me with
probably trying to breed rhinos now so
that that it you know that captive
rhinos and you can flood the market with
horn so that these crime syndicates
don't have this this need to kill you
know wild Ron doesn't make a fortune
it's you know it's because the Chinese
buy up this horn cuz it's not for DS
yeah it's got a medicinal qualities all
this [ __ ] so long as you eat the
rest of it
well they don't they just leave it
you've never had a rhino steak I've not
man relief not do you mean to tell me
you've never been to Cambodia for my
rule ah that's crazy so I would imagine
he was shot by by a high-powered rifle
it had to have been one of the dudes who
worked at Worth's in the park yeah
might have been a poacher might have
been just some guy I don't know man
that's that's mysterious
it could even be somebody who is trying
to aim at a lion yeah that's interesting
I gotta say it's well it's probably one
of those because those guys are like
badass those guys like the actual
African dudes who like take you into the
bush I know because I've been several
times don't it's it's not good for my
Hollywood rep you as you kill but so
don't tell anybody but what do you kill
like only elephants oh god man but are
they at least mature older elephants
anyway oh the old ones with the ears
that are falling apart yeah young cute
ones have roll around and kill the young
cute ones that roll around [ __ ] well why
in groups all by hands and I eat them
all wait you know where you been I
haven't seen you in yeah yeah it's
usually somewhere robust and you look
Noel fed yeah I'm in Kenya in a camp and
it takes a long time to eat take a long
time be one elephant yeah you jerk at
least do I jerk than me yeah jerk it
like as in do you create elephant jerky
Oh elephant jerky yes of course
yes so you'll you'll just go in there
with just a high-powered a
semi-automatic do you shoot from the
helicopter or what do you do nope I get
down on the floor and the floor
this is so
yeah and then and I bring my Ron Popeil
food dehydrator
oh no spare the spare the babies and the
moms at least nope oh god well what I
like to do really gonna ruin your career
we haven't seen a boa constrictor like
or not a boa constrictor but like a an
anaconda like eat something that it's
not like it can't quite get its yeah
sure
you should see when I like it get face
to face with a baby elephant and they
start chewing on its schnoz Oh No it's
which buttery poacher we open take a
bite out of Europe you take a bite out
of out of an elephant's trunk it's like
a piece of Turkish Delight all right do
but you're a poacher who eats its own
his own meat at least at least you're a
poet I eat it at least I eat it I mean
at least you stay just at elephants you
don't care my pictures of me all happy
with you know bunch of man you're gonna
ruin your career now as long as you just
eat as long as you just kill I guess I
could deal with elephants as long as
it's nothing else like you don't kill
river dolphins do you moon river dolphin
or adorable fortune all right I wouldn't
know I get in I get in the river with
the elephant bones and I fashion a net a
stop net whatever dogs off the dolphins
but there's no there euphrates you know
then I make a Cambodian build bring up
some river dolphins please there's no
such thing as River dog and there are
actually there are kinda yeah they're in
the Yangtze and they're so endangered
the poor things they're so awesome
oh I didn't know that they have to thing
yeah they're awesome yeah and they're
they're so endangered and that's why I
feel so guilty when I harpoon them yeah
I do but I do it for their own good
because I practice detachment uh yeah
they're amazing they're pink water
dolphins look at that when that
incredibly weird yeah and they're in the
they live in and the rivers of China the
Yangtze that's incredible
I had no idea like anything is a dolphin
in the river well I teach you a lot it's
a pink [ __ ] silver pink a river
dolphin poor things oh don't kill the
river dolphin river dolphin
all right um a pink dolphin though huh
how crazy is that River - it's in the
river there like an albino they're so
amazing
they're really cute I like them keep the
rivers Queen tasty they look no no no no
no I read wherever no no well they're
not free eating you you can't just have
your mouth drool over endangered specie
hey you want to go eat those you've
never eaten panda paws have you where do
you think we get the doughnut [ __ ] man
nothing better than a real panda Paul
all right let's move on from poaching
and see what else we have
[ __ ] man we've really is a very sweet
story a woman fell in love with a
homeless man and ended up marrying and
having kids with him well she'd leave he
was that homeless she found him in a
bush he wasn't from Amsterdam Holland
that just means he was probably trying
to get a job so he actually was
backpacking in Europe and then before he
knew it he lost he didn't have any more
money and he thought he would kind of
work around it and they were becoming an
alcoholic and then homeless and living
in a bush
yeah within five days he went on a bit
of a [ __ ] trip and then he met that
blonde whatever is fine homeless he
wasn't homeless
he's fine she looks first of all okay
very young guy plan better he should
plan better he's an [ __ ]
and she looks happy she looks happy he
looks like the kind of dick who would
bring a pheasant and tool or a peacock a
peacock [ __ ] he needs he's having an
affair with the peacock girl which they
won't tie a stupid haircut that's a dumb
haircut in it that actually is a
homeless guys first haircut
kind of haircut yeah it's like called
the hobo do ya that's where it's like
the most special yeah his hair is
naturally strength straight it's just
been matted up and dreadlocks Street
dreads yeah for so long that it looks
all curly so they're like hey we'll give
you some many little Justin Timberlake
1999's shoes because he's been barefoot
for so long yeah huge calluses yeah you
ever heard a Sarah Silverman she was
like I wanted to give him he had no
shoes but then have you ever seen a
homeless person after a while their feet
just become their own
since oh my god no yeah everybody grew
up in Trinidad in his feet like that
really yeah then he moved to I was like
that cuz he was just barefoot running
around Trinidad oh yeah you got some
thick calluses yeah you had thick thick
calluses you fetal adapt bro yeah yeah
your fetal [ __ ] adapt you'll you'll
build your own shoes I go hiking
barefoot doubt it
don't you got any more school yeah Super
Troopers - I just saw this that the it's
coming out in April yeah I just work
with Jay Chandrasekhar on the Culver was
in this and Kevin Heffernan was in your
Fu was and you're sure they're all funny
doesn't watch the trailer yeah they've
been waiting for a second chance waiting
for their country to need them again
that time yes meow what you guys give me
if I killed that bird forever that's a
bald eagle get away Baldy guys what do I
win a one-way ticket the hell it turns
out the French Canadian town st. George
junior raw is actually on American soil
you'll be phasing out a Canadian Mountie
unit best behavior boy not our idea of a
good time either fellas personally I'd
rather [ __ ] a moose he wouldn't need a
ladder to do that Wow let's give a big
Canadian welcome to the vanwall hi wait
guys they've come here to tell us how
great it's gonna be for all of us to
become Americans the Mountie in the back
with the beard looks cool good actor
enough stoichea does their column is Rob
Liefeld catcher Luc Robitaille Delta
interior Fran Tarkenton t-nut was there
that's funny I'm in that movie you are
yeah mother for you didn't see me nope I
didn't I'm one of the Mounties I'm one
of them evil male about that me Hayes
MacArthur and Tyler Labine you are you
really in it what do you mean really in
it go back let me see think you are cuz
you're there I am right there you are
there you are you [ __ ] [ __ ] you Brian
[Applause]
[ __ ] loser bloody loser you playing
it you [ __ ] besides I evil lies a big
[ __ ] silent [ __ ] with them with no
hair well we got a you know hey guess
what it pan out for your career did it
Brian what I'm just saying you're an
[ __ ]
Brian is sitting there I'll go all the
way up to Canada where I'm feeling
anyway no well we shot it in the same
thing
luckily I'm at the West in the same [ __ ]
and Anna Westin we have my thumbs we've
had a great fighting time to top my
[ __ ] he had a lot of late night yeah
pizza like in a movie window behind whoa
[ __ ] lock on the [ __ ] trailer
Brian [ __ ] trailer I'll tell you
another thing Brian great do I tell you
what you want to know something else can
do that a [ __ ] candle I'll tell you
something right now
right now it is award season Brian yeah
and for my performance and super trouper
to where I took to JC Chandor say card
said will you took some [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] not out of the [ __ ] party now
it's awards season and when I get my
award seems on either side of it I'm
gonna dedicate it to you Brian and then
I'm gonna stick it up your ass
don't go I said thank you hitting the
home runs what you're doing there I'm
stoked as [ __ ] [ __ ] and we had a
bunch of props throw thrown at us and
the boys look at them they're [ __ ]
acting
yeah they're doing [ __ ] no I'm [ __ ]
no worries about a hockey head getting
great job in the trailer ass my beard
looks a little red you look like an
[ __ ] you are an [ __ ] next next
story now now not the next door
that's it that's all yeah SuperDuper Stu
well April 20th 2018 everybody don't
forget to check out Loudermilk watch
Kevin probably saves the universe I also
got the burning woman of the Grizzlies
coming out of this year for any woman
they would do more obscure [ __ ] it's not
obscure what's burning woman in the
Grizzlies the burning woman it's me
she's on fire notes no all right that
script oh did you yeah yeah would you
think um nobody's gonna see it but
here's the thing
oh let's see Deadpool two official
trailer oh yeah I love that movie yeah
me too
I've seen Deadpool three times it's a
lot of great movies yeah it really is it
is let's watch this
he's so good hello there welcome back
I'm glad you could join me today let's
just drive right in and run all the
colors across so silly boy the fluid I'm
ready to go now let's grab our trusty 2
inch brush here just feed like it owes
you money we're gonna get a little damp
or yellow snow here mix that with just
another little dab of our baby water now
well that's just Danielson happy little
see I remember this is your world you
get to make and break the rules here
sweet baby Jesus wish I could jump in
there and roll around and all that
cascading white powder yeah just get
high and all of life's splendor god I
love cocaine so much
holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a kite
right ok
let's paint in a few little happy trees
there we're all without making friends
with trees now what you don't want to do
is eat these paints trust me on this one
what even is this no whack awesome Ken
this is a trailer for the movie that's
on us genius
oh my god she seems like we have
ourselves a finished painting so from
our family to yours it's amazing how
your dreams went and remember hugs tough
drugs holy [ __ ] this run of grace that's
one of the greatest [ __ ] trailers
I've ever seen in my life
that is so amazing Wow
oh I can't hurt a bit Brian that's what
it all comes down to that was so you
want to get your product across whether
it's the news and you're in that news
cycle yeah whether you're in the World
Wrestling Entertainment yeah field yeah
and you Ronda Rousey making a big
transition from in in-ring combat sure
to fake fighting is yeah yeah or whether
it's award season and you're out in
Cambodia yeah getting a cheap plastic
ward stuck up your ass while you try 51
year old dick hard no it's all about
entertainment Brian gown and that's my
gift to you today all right listen
my gift to your audience yeah this has
been I would try to get this hour and a
half back and I apologize to everybody
listen to the podcast to hear where the
10-minute podcast is going next it
doesn't matter yeah we're giving our
stuff to some guy named mark listen he
wanted listen thanks a lot it's
unlistenable when we're listening to the
entries of all the people who sent in
[ __ ] it's on listen we've had a lot of
entries only three of them even make
[ __ ] sense
and one guys just gonna get it or
another guy alright they show up the
bottom line here Brian is entertainment
okay and that's why I got in early this
morning coming home from Canada and
Brian hit me up yesterday yeah because
disorganized Brian listen DC this
weekend brand next weekend and then come
see me at Valentine's Day at Tempe
improv stand up live that Thursday
Friday Saturday following Valentine's
Day and will sasso go [ __ ] yourself
thanks everybody this has been a
disaster
give me that award I pull down on your
pants